what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing our x-men
videos and this is when things get
really really good because we pick up
with Messiah Complex I wanted to cover
the Nimrods story for a new x-men but I
can't find it I can't get my hands on it
but this is this is the whole thing so
when it comes to like the x-men relaunch
like this huge 10-year plan but it's not
really ten-year plan for the x-men it'd
be more like a six year plan for the
x-men you kind of have like landmark
stories hallmark stories and so one of
the stories that we haven't done is
something called endangered species now
endangered species was a one-shot and
then it became a bit of a branding
initiative but it wasn't really like a
huge long-standing thing endangered
species was kind of like this
consolidation of what was going on in
the sense that you had like the main
house of him event and then you had
decimation and the decimation spun out
into a whole bunch of different x-men
stories which consolidated down into
endangered species which are just kind
of like all the x-men coming together
for a funeral for the various mutants
who had died different things like that
or those kind of like a memorial for
those who had lost their powers and so
on and so forth and then it branches
back out into this again and so this is
kind of like the second wave so to speak
or at least like the start of the second
wave may be like like if you think about
it like the MCU this would be more like
Avengers like like the end of the first
wave and then after after a Messiah
Complex goes until like the second wave
which is the post Messiah Complex
landscape so like Second Coming and all
that kind of cool stuff this is what it
actually gets good like this is what
everything gets really really solid uh
having said that initially this story
picks up with the group on their way to
Alaska and here's the funny thing
I feel like we've done this before like
I feel like we've covered Messiah
Complex before but I went through all my
videos and I couldn't fought why didn't
go through all of them maybe searched
all my videos and I couldn't find it
anywhere and maybe it's one of those
things were like I've talked about it so
often and I've like gone through the
story to make sure that I had like the
facts right facts straight when I was
talking about it absolutely that all
does kind of coalesce ISM to tricking me
into thinking that we've done it before
I have no idea but regardless like this
opens up with the group basically
heading to Alaska so like the main x-men
team basically the uncanny x-men team
Nightcrawler storm Cyclops Wolverine
angel Warren Worthington I always forget
what his actual name is but their groups
basically heading towards Alaska and
we're not initially told why instead the
initial indication who are the initial
fear that they have is that it's
basically a trap that like they're going
out to Alaska and they're basically
going to be killed off now again this is
a legit
concern and it actually makes sense
because remember when you're the x-men
and the mutant population is reduced
down to 198 all the anti-mutant groups
are gunning for you I mean that's what
everything's been like that was the
whole basis of decimation decimation was
one part what are the what are the
mutants of the world doing now that
there's only 198 of them left give or
take a little bit and then like what are
all the groups who were anti-mutant
doing now that the mutant numbers are so
low that was really kind of like the
whole the whole basis behind the
decimation event and now this is the
kind of the cool thing here is that when
they get there initially Emma Frost
cannot picked up any of like the
thoughts of anybody in a local area but
as they get closer she begins to realize
that there are thoughts there but
they're sort of more emotions than
anything else meaning people are either
unconscious or they're in a state where
they're not thinking rationally ie
they're all terrified and when they get
to the small little town here in in
Alaska and they when they get to this
location we basically end up finding out
that like the whole place is a war zone
like it's all been torn to pieces and so
at this point we jump to several hours
before all this happened before they
were on this mission and we pick up with
Professor X and Beast hain't McCoy now
the idea is that of course Professor X
is basically using cerebro to kind of
analyze the earth and see if there's any
new mutant readings this is really more
of like a false thing I mean Xavier kind
of knows it's nonsense to do this but he
does it anyway because in his mind
there's a possibility that like new
mutants might rise up something else
that I want to point out here - and I
want to kind of hit on this for a second
the idea of the Scarlet Witch stripping
98% of the mutant population of their
powers was initially believed to have
only been involved as part of like the
main Marvel continuity it wasn't until
later on down the line that we found out
that it actually sweep all across the
multiverse no that's not a huge you know
plot spoiler for any of the stories that
we're gonna do later on but the reason
why this matters is because you can
actually extrapolate that for example
during the story of old man Logan
there's a point where he comes across
and meets Emma Frost and Emma Frost
makes the statement that like mutants
were just a blip on the radar you could
actually argue and infer that the
Scarlet Witch was the reason why that
happened I think it makes it a little
more intriguing and a little more
interesting but regardless in the midst
of basically you know using cerebro and
analyzing the planet Earth suddenly
Xavier experiences a psychic feedback
and it's not just Charles Xavier it
literally starts shattering parts of the
Xavier Institute Emma Frost experiences
a psychic feedback the various
electronic devices inside the Xavier
Institute start freaking out but the eye
like a being has been born with a mutant
gene so astronomically powerful that it
can basically overpower Charles Xavier
and he can send a clash ISM and end
waves of all kinds of psychic energy all
throughout the world is nothing to scoff
at and at the very least it's the birth
of a new meeting Charles Xavier looks at
this and says this is the birth of hope
is what this is this is the birth of
Hope of the mutant population returning
to the way that it used to be and so we
pick back up with the current moment as
us going on right now and again they're
survivors here I mean not everyone who's
here is dead I mean they will be if the
x-men don't act which of course they do
you know Nightcrawler teleports around
starts grabbing people getting them out
of there but Wolverine looks at the
scene and immediately says this was not
some kind of an accident because the
thoughts of the x-men is that well maybe
this this new mutant you know whatever
their power is it manifested like maybe
they have some kind of destructive power
over intercepts in it so this is not
what's going on here this is a war zone
because as they start to go through the
area what they begin to realize is that
there are Marauders here not only are
there Marauders there's also purifiers
and this is a pretty big deal because
when it comes to the Marauders they're
basically the henchmen of mr. sinister
and mr. sinister is a mutant geneticist
each hampers with the genes of various
people but he only ever sends the
Marauders out when someone needs to be
eliminated this is kind of hearkening
back to the days of the mutant massacre
whenever people think of the Marauders
like whatever the x-men look at the idea
of the Marauders they think you know
going into the sewers of New York
eradicating all these different Morlocks
and so when they see them here in this
town in Alaska the thought is oh my god
they're here to kill whoever this moon
is now the purifiers we've talked about
them before me if you guys are new here
if the purifiers are just like religious
fanatics they believe that God wants
them to kill mutants and so then being
here is a huge deal too and so what this
indicates is that the birth of this
mutant did not go unnoticed by all these
various groups outside of the x-men
Charles Xavier was just one of the
people who became aware of what was
going on not only that the idea that
this mutant came into existence and
basically sent out this psychic backlash
there's no absolute guarantee that the
the two were are you know happened
simultaneously which is to say that when
Emma Frost sits down and basically says
look this is not like a a teenage mean
this is a baby mutant a kid who is
basically born and their powers
manifested the idea is that it's
entirely possible that the powers
manifested when all these groups started
showing up and that's when the psychic
back
went out and we know that because when
the x-men arrived they say it's been
about an hour or so now again this is
just kind of inferring things I mean in
truth it is the birth of this mutant
that said all these things in motion
that brought everybody here the question
has to be asked is what took them so
long what are the purifiers and the
Marauders get here faster than the x-men
did but Emma Frost going through and
basically tapping into the mind of one
of the survivors it plays out exactly
like we liked like we would expected to
the purifiers show up and the purifiers
basically start killing everybody who's
a kid their hands off the adults because
they're not there to kill an adult
they're there to kill a young child
who's mutant powers recently manifested
now notice this if what you guys thought
about the purifiers before was pretty
heinous in terms of the fact of them
like attacking a busload of kids who are
who were deep Howard but we're still
considered mutants at one point in time
this is even worse because they kill
every child they come across in this
town every single kid and it's extreme
not only that you also have the group
that's met by the arrival of the
Marauders one of which is gambit so
again this is huge and this is an
intense moment because both of these
groups start battling against one
another I mean you have gambit of course
having been a member of the x-men and
the various Marauders who are working
for sinister who were able to achieve
their goal and taking out pretty much
all the purifiers but Warren Worthington
goes into one of the local hospitals and
realizes that like newborns were taken
out by that by the purifiers I mean
they're extreme guys like that's the
whole idea behind it this all goes back
to Chris Claremont with God loves man
kills the extreme nature of the
purifiers to do whatever it is that they
have to do I mean like that was the
opening scene for God loves man kills
two kids at a playground being shot and
killed by the purifiers it's extreme and
it's enough's and is pretty intense but
that's the nature of the group so
ultimately the x-men basically began to
look around and realize there's nothing
for them here the baby that was here is
gone it's been taken by someone or some
group they don't know who but they
suspect it to be mr. sinister and that's
a pretty dire situation if mr. sinister
got his hands on this newborn mutant
then like any number of things could
happen so again I mean for the most part
we know what's going on right now but I
mean you know let yourself live in the
moment guys let the kayfabe take over
you but still it is it is interesting
because what is up happening is yes I'm
basically just sort of bail out they did
they ultimately just say whatever you
know we're kind of gone and we're
leaving here so what we do is we pick up
with this organism called predator X now
Predator X does actually have an origin
and it took place in the mercury falling
story arc for new x-men and I want to
say it was issues 33 through 36 and I'm
not gonna swear to that and I probably
should look that up to make sure that
I'm right but regardless the whole
predator x concept was actually launched
by William Stryker himself William
Stryker who was the head of the
purifiers before he was eliminated he
basically created predator had pointed
Rex created as a back-up plan and
predator X actually has organic metal
skin so pretty much the same kind of
skin to a degree as Colossus in fact I
think it is the exact same kind of skin
as Colossus
but predator X was designed for the
purpose of just like seeking out mutants
and feeding on their genes but in this
instance this predator X is seeking out
one particular mutant specifically the
mutant that was born here so again it's
all these different things coming
together and coalescing on this one
situation and so what this does is
basically continue on into the greater
Messiah complex storyline that follows
the aftermath of all these things
ultimately running up to the revelation
of who this mutant baby is and what
happened to it and who or what group it
was that took this child away but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explain and
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the robb cork if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]